i want to stress is purely
a pakistan initiative it's an initiative
taken by us we haven't been asked by
anyone to
do this it is our initiative and i
repeat because
it is imperative that we do not allow a
conflict to take
place because and i again repeat there's
a vested interest
that wants this to happen and so
i've been very encouraged
talking to you mr president i feel
encouraged and
i will i go in a very positive
frame of mind to saudi arabia and we
will act
i repeat as a facilitator not a mediator
a facilitator we would like to
facilitate talks
uh as you mentioned in our during our
conversation
in the past pakistan has hosted saudi
arabia and iran
in islamabad in the past to iron out
your differences
and so we are again willing to do the
same thing
we again want to facilitate our two
brotherly countries
to uh to iron out your differences
and i repeat again it's it's
complicated it's complex but i feel it's
possible
to resolve these differences
is he put it two brotherly countries to
iron out
their differences he said that this
initiative
was a purely pakistani initiative
and he promised to act as a facilitator
rather than a mediator
pointing to pakistani efforts in the
past where he said that they had
hosted talks between
iranian and saudi officials said it
to realize that conflict is in nobody's
interest
and he warned that there were vested
interests as he put
it seeking that and that would be a very
dangerous thing
he warned for the region
this of course comes at a very sensitive
and critical time
for a number of those conflicts which
have been
raging in the region in new york
president trump spoke to me and he
wanted to facilitate
us to facilitate some sort of dialogue
between
iran and the united states
we discuss things in details
we i know again there are difficulties
involved
but again we will whatever we can do to
facilitate this dialogue
so that the sanctions are lifted and uh
and a nuclear deal is signed between the
two countries
again whatever we can do we will
happy to facilitate but we discuss the
in details the issues involved and we
recognize
that iran has certain uh issues about it
so
so this is an ongoing process and if we
can help
we will be willing to facilitate in the
future
and then i think we just heard
pakistan's prime minister
try to step in as a facilitator at the
very least to try and
sort out some of the tension around
iran's nuclear programme
he uh referenced there his desire to
facilitate a dialogue he said until a
nuclear deal
is signed between the two countries were
his words
that of course has been a very sensitive
issue
since the rise of the trump
administration
in the united states of america where we
saw of course
the us withdraw from the
agreement which the u.s had previously
signed
with iran over the curbs put in place to
check iran's nuclear
programme
foreign
all right so there we have seems to be
the conclusion of that
press conference by the prime minister
of pakistan
and the president of iran